seen a lot of stuff in the news late
government quarter and place cuts and
the government cutting away of funds on
the face and what not in the end we just
got cigarettes for a while
you've got to do something you've got to
be proactive you can't just sitting put
a little pour soda in arms ticklish [ __ ]
on Twitter obvious with any of the
social media and sure we start a
distance it sort of just went from there
[Music]
we are comments got a group of two
people who deployed online profiles
before to be females on meals from 11 to
15 and if I don't instigate conversation
and start to talk sexual and want to
meet up we'll follow along without
meetin and get the police enforce arrest
them and get them put through the system
let's not like all right how old was the
girl that you are here to meet all right
okay so anybody I'm talking about eBay
I'm asking way all the way from liver to
Alyssa no I'm not least by to not walk
around in this area then what I'm saying
so to get your sample here now looking
on next year carne okay I don't know
nothing you can tell me what you thought
was a foodie you all feel that you're in
a chat room
yes if it's okay because I'm kind of
disappointed really that the police are
not supporting the online activists more
I think that it's really important for
them to work together and to work also
with serve the organization's as well I
think what they're doing is it's about
combating this sense of hopelessness
that we feel as a society we hear all
that these stories about child sex abuse
we don't know what to do but actually
child sexual abuse is an entirely
preventable crime it's not like digit
use it's not about microbes it's not
about natural disasters it's simply
about human choices and human actions so
we can always change it I mean we will
do tellin lies that we said it didn't
make us depressed it doesn't mean like
anyone who doesn't want to tree at the
chair the child is seeing a mom and are
like that picture sterile I have to
verify you know I mean I'll never get
ing classroom on screen so far
mrs. y7 phosphate you know lighting that
all that kicks website more picture
ladies penises move this picture very
famous a defense of like each other a
hunger in the bed on the side at night
when he's meeting and obviously but I
got a big shop and if you delicately
mobile setup for do all this use we
found out Murray dance with partner well
you know you're extremely radical so the
pictures of this guy fell would indicate
to me that maybe Eagles have a child or
something because if you look in the
background enough each other it looks
like for like a beanbag like a postman
powerful isn't that vindicated we could
indicate he's on the child or
announcement children's then over on
East 38th you see he stopping yourself
it's not illegal but in my mind I mean
thinks or believes into the
thirteen-year-old girl definitely
inappropriate the real life a
thirteen-year-old girl wouldn't say that
she'll be really excited that somebody
fines are attracted and wants to be like
this guy here would you consider date in
the gamma a is going to be Wow really
what you like me that like evenings
definitely has seen each other so this
is straight away or to do with
exploitation but nothing to do with
because we go out to a bar and you see
somebody that's going to be your age or
around your age you know it's been the
attraction sisters of that this is
nothing like that at all
this is complete exploitation by
individuals who use the Internet
incoming video requests from day so the
minute I say no in reality what the
thirteen-year-old girl do at home in the
privacy of her own bedroom should turn
on so you know but then again I've got
more 12 up there now
so to lose one isn't a bad thing so I'm
going to close it down close next stage
Republicans are not have to those who
support it because no offenses have been
done that's how quick it is I would say
out of those I would get at least six if
not seven but I would have to close them
down so I'd need to deal with one two
three or four because obviously it gets
very hard to deal with so yeah you know
their potential and some of them already
have 38 year old from sorry saying you
want to date me well that can only mean
one thing
why do girls respond so when an adult
man decides to chat up a 13 year old
girl online why doesn't she just say
what a weirdo you know and not respond
and report him to the police and I think
one of the key reasons why girls don't
do that is because we as a society have
already groomed her to think that that
sort of behavior is acceptable and I was
growing up like it was normal for like
eating knurled large to where it was
like 12 year old buses it wasn't a
ravier problem it was just like well
being content to like not my eyes
obviously for like to the today a friend
group it was normal like the Russell's
would hang out with them and they were
like getting they need funny but did
that kind of implement what are you guys
doing now working lovers it would have
been not like was a normal way you were
like yeah that one's a lot you know like
20 year olds going out with like 13 14
yeah we have another luckiest girl who
was like like 13 and the boyfriend was
like see if you ask you know the name
iris we she's being brainwashed by this
person into believing you know the lies
that he's obviously better or you know I
often barely to have the mouth we know
from a recent study that was done
that the majority of girls at school are
facing such a harassment and sexual
abuse at school so three-quarters of all
girls at school I used to being called
names like flag or flood or [ __ ] on a
regular daily basis about half of all
girls at school experience sexual
harassment and almost the third of all
girls experience some form of unwanted
sexual touching at school and things
like you know boys are sending them
photographs of their penises stuff like
that at school so then when it happens
online with our domain they don't know
that a line has been crossed there
because they're used to having very
confused boundaries about what sexually
healthy what sexually normal so I've got
intercepts for you what after an event
rich X I'll decide who you meet and when
okay so like this we want to meet the
girl first and then trust that
throughout - you spider the sick from
the frenzy on aleni
as far as a sixth finger at the reader
they all like young girls
show legs be nice but non-smoking option
unless you wanna you see they're very
very success and then he goes on that
his servers are on this they're there to
be she can call and whities da boss and
I the sling important ally wanted anyone
server as some sort of sexual contact
with his dog while he watches and then
he was saying she could put one hand on
the bulkiness of on hand on his penis
and doing some BOTS I'm eternally excite
always going to get the shot his life on
the home front the mencius oh I hated
ear
[Music]
one
yes
music went down you up in spin
yes for the booking a fifteen-year-old
over on actually rejected I am yes so
that your words both women are fine sir
very successful there when you beat him
down outside
what we're gonna get rich by as you
please
comedies that means 240-volt inaudible
right he was arrested when you was in my
local gas project officer
Ellucian saying that there could be even
on America circa 1900 total like Pierre
message there one of those people part
on that and the blimp has been some
reports we actually spoke see if they're
going to actually actually mean what he
wants to do and go another supermarket
it was god-awful aliens by French and
from a specialist in only eventually
it's not a non-sustainable main facade
yesterday even for homos yes in trouble
from a month or and problem the air nor
forgiveness out in Holland are we're
given with accessibility
you may have various speed alleged okay
your based on absorbance I agree
occasionally maybe go
[Music]
[Music]
we've been
maybe troubles when he turned up
extra
people like right man come children
Devon
[Music]
[Music]